If you are going to travel to Europe
and you don't want to run out of internet,
this may be useful.
In Europe
the most normal thing to do is to arrive and buy a chip to have
internet throughout your trip.
I used to buy a chip when I arrived at the airport,
but I never pulled well,
so the best option is to stick it out and not buy anything.
At the airport.
Arriving at your destination,
go out and look for a Vodafone.
I arrived in Madrid and the closest one was the Gran Via.
There you will see that they have packages
very cheap and with lots of internet.
I bought a 50 giga package
for €10 and with that I had internet for my whole trip.
and not only in Spain
but in all the other countries we visit.
And well no friends,
this is not a commercial,
It's just that it's what has worked best for me.
Now that
if Vodafone wants to send me some chips
for when I go to Europe
again,
who am I to say no?
Greetings